nato warplanes patrolling the baltic
region this week but now this
long-standing policing operation has
been bolstered danish fighter jets
deployed to nato's edge in lithuania and
the welcome ceremony for the personnel
was a public occasion for a reason
designed to send a message to russia the
lithuanian president telling sky news
the talking isn't over but nato is
preparing for all eventualities
president mused many people in this
region say the time for diplomacy has
passed do you agree
i don't agree i think the time for
diplomacy is still there
and we have to talk we have to send very
clear messages to
some countries which are trying to
increase attention in the region
the danish air force flew in four f-16
jets to lithuania as part of a
developing nato strategy to deter
military action by russian forces who've
massed in their tens of thousands on
ukraine's border that is the main role
of nato in peace time it's deterrence
and reassurance and i believe that this
is part of that and hopefully that will
be
they will do the job and do the
deterrence and that will work but
it's worrying what we're seeing now
a few extra jets may be welcome but what
countries on nato's eastern flank really
want to see is thousands of nato boots
on the ground many argue the only
language vladimir putin really
understands is that of visible military
strength
concern has grown in the baltic states
in recent days as russian forces and
equipment have moved into belarus the
two nations now carrying out joint
military exercises a pivotal moment
according to lithuania's deputy minister
for national defence he says russia's
sphere of military influence has now
extended dangerously to immediately
cross his country's border and to nato's
edge this is a game changer
game changer and we've been warning
partners about
that possibility for a
number of of years it is a direct threat
to not only to the feign and
regional countries in the region but
also for nato
because it means that we have a
significant uh number of of russian
troops next to nato borders
and we cannot rule out any any scenario
a worrying thought not just for
politicians in the military but the
citizens of the baltic nations who are
now looking to the nato alliance for
confidence and support
michelle clifford sky news lithuania